hi folks
um why don't we get started
um
welcome back
good to see you
you all here
so um
i am going to
first
we'll
we'll recap what we did last time and
what we're going to do today i'll talk a
little bit about the problem set
and we'll also have a break as requested
halfway through
so why don't we jump in um what we did
last time um was we introduced finite
besides introduce introducing the course
we introduced finite automata and
regular languages which are the
languages that the finite automata can
recognize
we talked about these regular operations
um and the and then building um those
those allow us to build what we call our
regular expressions these are
ways of describing languages so find we
have finite automata can describe
languages and regular expressions can
describe languages and one of our goals
is to show that those two systems are
equivalent to one another even though
they look rather different um at first
glance
so um to
move in that direction we first
proved uh we're going to prove closure
properties for all of the
for the class of regular languages over
these regular operations so we'll show
that
well we already showed that any two
regular languages have their union also
being regular and we'll show that for
the other two operations as well so
let's just look ahead to what we're
going to do today
we're going to introduce an important
concept which is going to be a theme
throughout the course called
non-determinism
and we
uh
having that as a tool
that we can use will be able to show
closure under concatenation and star
finishing up what we started to do last
time
and then we'll use those closure
constructions to show how to convert
regular expressions to finite finite
automata
um and that's going to be halfway to our
goal of showing that the
two systems are equivalent to one one
another and the following lecture we
will show how to do the conversion in
the other direction
so i thought we would just jump in then
and look at um return to the material of
the course
um as you remember
we were
looking at the closure properties for
the class of regular languages
um we started doing that um and if you
recall hopefully uh we did closure under
union and then we tried to do closure
under concatenation um which i have
shown here
um on the slide um you know the what the
proof attempt
that we tried to do last time and let's
just review that quickly because i think
that's going to be uh helpful to see how
to fix the problem that came up um so if
you remember um we had a uh
you know we're given two regular
languages a1 and a2 and we're trying to
show that the concatenation language a1
a2 is also regular
and so the way we you know the way we go
about all of these things is you know we
assume that a1 and a2 are regular so
that means we have machines finite
automata for a1 and a2 we'll call them
m1 and m2
that recognize a1 and a2 respectively
and then what we need to do in order to
show that concatenation is
regular is to make a finite automaton
which recognizes the concat nation
and we tried to do that last time um
so uh if you remember that concatenation
machine m we're calling it
uh what is it supposed to do
it's supposed to accept its input if
it's in the concatenation language and
that means that the input can be split
into two parts x and y
where x is in the a language and y is in
the b line and in the end y is accepted
by m1 and x is accepted by m1 and y's
accepted by m2 sorry garbled that
uh so x should be in a1 and y should be
in a2
um if you can split w that way then m
should accept it so m has to make
figure out if there's some way to split
the input
so that the first machine accepts the
first part the second machine accepts
the second part
and
um the idea that we came up with for
doing that
was to
um
take these two machines
build them in to a a new machine m
and then connect the accepting states
for m to the start state
connect the the accepting states for m1
to the start state for m2
um because the idea would be that if m1
has accepted an initial part you want
then you want to pass control to m2 to
accept the rest
but as we observed that doesn't quite
work because
um the first place to split w
after you found an initial part that's
accepted by m1 may not be the right
place because the remainder may not be
accepted by m2 you might have been
better off waiting until you found
another place that m1 accepted later on
in the stream say over here
and then
uh by splitting it over there then maybe
you do get successfully find that the
remainder is accepted by m2 whereas if
you tried to split it
you know the first place the remainder
wouldn't have been accepted by m2 so all
you need to do you know m has to know is
there someplace to split the input so
that you know you can get both parts
accepted by the respective machines
the problem is is that m might need to
know the future in order to know where
to make the split
and it doesn't have access to the future
so what do we do
um so what we're going to do is
introduce a new concept
that will allow us to
uh basically get the effect of m1
in the sort of being able to see the
future
um and that new concept is going to be
very important for us throughout the
term it's called non-determinism and so
we're going to introduce a new kind of
finite automaton called a
non-deterministic finite automaton and
first we'll look at that and then we'll
see how that fits in with the previous
deterministic finite automaton that we
introduced last time
so here's an example we're always good
to start off with an example
um here is an a picture of a
non-deterministic fine art automaton
looks very similar at first glance to a
to the former kind the deterministic
finite automaton
but if you look a little carefully you
see that there are some key differences
um the most important difference
is that
um
[Music]
the in state q1 for example
whereas in the machines that we
introduced last time
there had to be exactly one way to go on
each possible input symbol so you knew
how to you know how to follow along
through the machine as its computing
here there are two ways to go
in q1 you can either stay in q1 or you
can go to q2
that's the essence of non-determinism
there could be many ways to proceed
um
and furthermore on q1 if you get a b
then there's nowhere to go
so
um that's uh also possible within
non-determinism there could be um so
let's let's just start looking at these
features
there are multiple paths forward but
multiple paths possible you might be
able to have uh one as we had before or
many ways to go at each step or maybe
zero ways to go at each step those are
all legitimate for a non-deterministic
machine which doing a non-deterministic
computation
another difference if you look carefully
is that we're allowing here the empty
string to appear on a transition
that's perhaps a little less uh
essential to the spirit of
non-determinism but it's going to turn
out to be a convenience when we actually
apply non-determinism to build machines
as you'll see very shortly
now if there are many different ways to
go
and
some of those ways to go might have
different outcomes
you know as we remember from before we
accepted the input if you end up in an
accept state
and we rejected the input if you end up
not in an except state in a
non-accepting state then you reject
but now there might be several different
ways to go
um
so and we'll do an example in a minute
but there might be several different
ways to go and they might disagree
some of them might accept other ones
might reject so then what do you do
well in that case
um acceptance always overrules rejection
that's the essence of non-determinism
the way we're def the way we're setting
it up
um you may ask why that is and you know
if um sort of the spirit of that will
become clear in due course but right now
just take it as a rule when we're having
a non-deterministic machine acceptance
overrules rejection
so as long as there is one accepting
copy
one one of the possible ways to go ends
up at an accept we say the whole thing
is accepted
um the only way could possibly reject if
all of the possible ways to go end up at
rejection end up at a non-accept state
so we'll see example we'll i think we're
going to do an example right now yeah so
we take for example um this machine n1
now on an input a b
and we're going to process the symbols
one by one just like we did before
but now to follow along there might be
several different ways to go
so if we take um
the
uh
the first
symbol a
and we run the machine so the machine is
starts at the start state um as before
but now an a comes in and there might be
two now there are two different ways to
go so we're going to keep track of both
of them
after the machine reads an a you can
think of it as think of it as being in
two states now simultaneously it can be
in state q one and it can be in state q
two so those are two different possible
places it could be at this moment
okay
now um now we read the next symbol
the b and from a b you take all of each
of the places where the machine could be
um at the end of the previous symbol
and you then apply
reading a b the next symbol to each of
those uh from each of those states where
the machine could be in uh from the
previous symbol
so the machine could be in q1 and q2
after reading an a now we apply a b well
q one on a b
goes nowhere
so
you think of that uh
a branch
if you will of the computation as just
dying off it has nowhere to go it just
vanishes
however when you're in the the other
possibility which was state q2 on a b
does allow does have a place to go so
that the machine is now going to go from
q2 to q3 um uh
when it re on that branch of the
computation which reading on reading a b
and then
it has
um
[Music]
uh
coming out of q3 there are two symbols
there's an a and an empty string symbol
now on an a the machine would have to
read
an a in order to transition along that
arrow
but on when there's an empty symbol on
the arrow that means the machine can go
along that arrow for free without even
reading anything
as long as it gets to q3 it can
automatically jump to q4
and so
once it has read a b and gone to q3
now
um it it can either stay in q3 or it can
re it can go along the empty transition
and go to q4 so again it is going to be
a non-deterministic step at this point
um
[Music]
the essence of having a empty transition
is that there's going to be
non-determinism that's why we didn't
introduce that
for deterministic automata because
um you don't have to transition along an
empty string transition you can stay
where you are or you can go along the
empty string transition without reading
any input and go over to the next state
which in this case is q4
so let's just see where we are after
reading an a we're in states q1 q2
but now after reading a b we're in
states q3 and q4 as possibilities and
then we and now we're at the end of the
input and we look and see what we got
if any one of the states as
possibilities that we are right now at
the end of the string is an accept state
then we say overall the machine has
accepted
so that corresponds to what we said over
here before accept the input if some
path leads to an accept
so if any way of proceeding
um through these you know
non-deterministic choices will lead you
to an accept then you will say we're
going to accept the input
okay so this input here is accepted
let's do another example suppose we have
the input a a
instead of a b
so a a
you know after the first a as before
we're in states q one and q two as
possibilities
now we read in a again
now the one that's on state q one that
possibility q one possibility after
reading an a it again branches to q1 and
q2
um
so when we know after reading the second
a we're going to be in at least q1 and
q2 now how about the
the state that had been you know on q2
on reading in a
the one from before after reading the
first day you were in q2 now reading the
second a there's nowhere to go so that
one just gets removed
so after reading a a
we remain in states q1 and q2 as
possibilities
neither of those are accept states
so therefore on input a a
the machine rejects
okay
let's just do a couple more and then
i'll ask you to do one
so
we have aba as an input let's see what
happens then so
um we have a
uh
remember after reading a b a b
the machine is in the two states q three
q four as possibilities that's what we
had from from um the first example
so after reading a b we're in states two
three q four now we read another a
the confu the q4
on an a has nowhere to go in fact it has
nowhere to go on any input so no matter
what comes in after you're in state q4
that branch dies
but on q3 which is another one of the
possibilities reading in a um it can
follow along just transition because
that's one of the labels on that
transition is a so you can follow along
just a transition reading in a which is
the last uh
symbol in the string and so now after
aba you are in only state q4
as a possibility but that happens to be
an accept state so the machine accepts
um
okay and now lastly what happens let's
take our final examples uh what happens
if we have a b b
so
you know as you remember before when we
um were after reading a b that was the
first example we were in states q3 q4 as
possibilities now we read a b
well neither of those states have
anywhere to go on a b
so now all
threads all branches of the computation
die off
and at this point the machine is totally
dead it has no no active possibilities
left
so certainly it's going to reject this
input because none of the active states
there are no active states are accepting
states and in fact if you looked at
anything that came later
they would anything that extended the
string a b b would also be rejected
because once the machine had all
all possibilities have died off there's
no way for them to uh come back to life
on any extensions
so with that um
oh here's an important point before i
i'm going to jump to a check-in on you
uh but um
uh i think what one thing that you know
might be on your mind about this
non-determinism is how does how do we
actually what is that how does that
correspond to reality
well it doesn't
um
we're not intending for non-determinism
as we're defining it to correspond to a
physical device
but nevertheless as you'll see it's a
very mathematically useful concept uh
this non-determinism and it's going to
be playing a big role throughout the
subject as will uh
as will experience it during the rest of
the term
so with that uh i'm going to have a
little check in it's going to give i'm
going to ask you to
uh consider what happens on one of the
inputs um so here we go what does it do
on input a a b
so here's the machine you can look at it
and i'm gonna i'm supposed to hopefully
there's a poll here for me to give to
you um
so you can
uh
give me your input
so what does the machine do on input a
a b
most of you have answered
again you're not going to be penalized
for getting the wrong answer
um but
uh
hopefully
you you'll get the right answer
anyway
let's just take a look here uh so time
is up
um let's end the polling
and share the results
so the majority of you majority have
gotten the correct answer which is a the
machine does accept a a b
uh because you know when you have
a
so if you if you like i'll show you the
path that corresponds to accepting you
go a
a
b
and then empty string
and so
that
uh
uh sequence of steps
is one of the non-deterministic
possibilities that the machine can
follow
and that shows that the machine does
accept the input a a b you know you
could think about it the way we did it
before um also you know if you read an a
it's in the two possibilities q one q
two you read a second a again in the
possibilities q one q two now you read a
b
it's into possibilities q three q four
and um that's it
a a b so now you read the b it's in
possibility q three q four q four is an
accepting state that overrules the
non-accepting state and so the machine
accepts
you have to understand this so if you
didn't get it right
go back and think about where you
slipped up
okay because this is um
you know the
you know
this is just getting we're just getting
warmed up
here it's going to get it's going to get
a lot harder
okay so stop sharing the results um
and
so let's continue
so now
we just as we did last time we can
formally uh define a fine
non-deterministic finite automata here's
the picture again um
okay uh so it looks a lot like the the
the case we had before the deterministic
finite automata or dfa as we'll call
them um it's a five tuple so i've sort
of
uh written down little reminders for
what those components of that five tuple
are that list of five uh
five components um
so they're all the same as before
states alphabet
transition function start state and
accepting states so that the formal
definition definition looks exactly the
same except the structure of the
transition function
so now before if you remember you had a
state and an input symbol and you got
back a state
uh now we have something more
complicated looking
we have a state and an input symbol
but it you know it's instead of just
sigma it's sigma sub epsilon and that
that's a shorthand for sigma union
epsilon
and that's a way my way of saying that
you're allowed to have on your
transition um arrows either an input
symbol or an empty string so the
transition function has to tell you what
to do when you have empty string coming
in as well um so that would be part of
your table for the transition function
now over here what's going on over here
well now
instead of just producing a single state
you know when you've read for example an
a
on from q1 there's a whole set of
possibilities
so here we have what's called the power
set
that's the set of
subsets
of the collection queue
so here we're going to produce an entire
subset of states instead of just one
state coming out there might be a subset
of possible states that you can go to
so the power set of q is the set of
subsets of um of q
so
that's what this notation means
um
again this is something that
i'm hopefully presenting to you as a bit
of a reminder you've seen this somewhere
else before but um please make sure you
understand the notation uh going forward
because
we'll we'll be doing less hand-holding
as we start moving forward
um
okay
so just let's take a look at the n1
example here
um just to illustrate the illustrate
what's going on when you're in state q1
reading an a
now you get a whole set of possibilities
which in this case is q1 and q2
um whereas if you're reading a b what
would be that set
coming out of q1 what's the set of
possible successor states
well there are none so it's the empty
set
okay so this is
hopefully your understanding no notation
here so now here's i think really
important
how do we understand non-determinism
intuitively speaking and there are
multiple different ways which each has
their value under different
circumstances
so one way
is
thinking about non-determinism as a kind
of parallelism
so every time the machine has a
non-deterministic choice to make where
there is more than one outcome you think
of the machine as um
[Music]
branching forking
new threads of the parallel computation
at that stage where it makes entire copy
of itself when there's a choice of
possibilities
and then each of those independently
proceeds to read the rest of the input
as separate threads of the computation
so if you're familiar with parallel
computing this should be reasonably
familiar to you the only key thing to
remember is that as this thing forks
number possibilities
the acceptance rule is that if any one
of those possibilities gets to an accept
at the end of the input it raises a flag
and says accept and that overrules
everybody else
so acceptance dominates
so another way of looking at it is the
mathematical view
where you can imagine and we're going to
use all these so it's you really need to
understand them all the mathematical
view
is if you can think of the computation
as kind of a tree of possibilities
so you start off at the very beginning
sort of at the root of the computation
which is that when it really begins but
every time there's a non-deterministic
branching that occurs
um the tree has
[Music]
that note of the tree has
uh multiple children coming out of that
node and so the different threads of the
computation correspond to different
branches of that tree
and now you're going to accept if any
one of those branches leads to an
accepting state
okay very obviously somewhat similar to
what we had before but it's i think it's
a little bit of a different perspective
on what not how to think about
non-determinism
and the last one is going to sound a
little weird
but actually i think
for people who are
in the business
it's the one they use the most
and that's the magical way of thinking
about non-determinism
and that is
um
when the machine has non-deterministic
choices to make
you think of the machine as magically
guessing the correct one at every stage
and the correct one being the one that
will eventually lead to accept
okay so you can think of the machine as
guessing
which is the right way to go
and if there is some way right way to go
it always guesses right of course if the
machine ends up rejecting because there
is no right way to go then it doesn't
matter there is no good guess
but if there is some good guess we'll
think of the machine as taking that good
guess and going that way
okay
so
um
now here is very important thing we
introduced this new model
uh the uh the non-deterministic
foundation nfa
it turns out to be
even though it looks more powerful
because has this non-determinism it
isn't any more powerful it can do
exactly the same class of languages the
regular languages and we'll show that
um with the theorem here that if an nfi
and
if an nfa recognizes a then a is regular
um
[Music]
so
um
we'll prove that by showing how to
convert an nfa to an equivalent dfa
which does the same language so we can
take an nfa that has a non-determinism
and find another dfa which doesn't have
non-determinism but does the same
language it accepts exactly the same
strengths
even though it lacks that
non-deterministic capability
it's this is going to be extremely
useful by the way and for example in
showing that closure under concatenation
okay
so
uh you know in this
presentation here i'm going to ignore
the epsilon transitions because once you
get the idea for how to do this you
could figure out how to incorporate them
they just make things a little more
complicated so let's just focus on the
key aspect of non-determinism which is
that the machine could have several ways
to go at any point in time
there could be several next states
on an input
okay
now the idea for the construction so
we're going to take we're going to start
with a non-deterministic machine m
and we're going to build a deterministic
machine m prime which does exactly the
same thing
and the way m prime works is it's going
to do what you would do
if you were simulating m
what would you do with me this is what
we were doing as we were as i was
explaining it to to you
if you are simulating m every time you
get an input symbol you just keep track
of what is the set of possible states at
that point in time
that's what the dfa is going to do
it's going to have
uh
it's going to have to keep track
of which possible set of states the nfa
could be in
at the
point on that input where we are right
now
and then
as you get the next symbol
the dfa is going to have to update
things to keep track of the next set of
states the nfa could be in at this point
just like you would do
okay and so
um
so here's a kind of a picture
um
and
how do we implement that in in so here's
the nfa that we're starting with m and
we're going to make here the dfa
but um
in order to remember
which set of states that dfa could be in
at a given point so maybe it's the set
of states that it that m could be in
did i say that wrong which set of states
the nfa could be at a given time so
maybe m the nfa could be in
at some point state q3 and q7
the way the dfa keeps track of that it's
going to have a state for every possible
subset of states
of the nfa
that's how it re remembers which subset
of states the nfa is in that's the way
dfas work they have a separate state for
each possibility that they need to keep
track of
and the possibilities here are the
different subsets of states that the nfa
could be in at a given point
okay so
corresponding to this subset to these
two possibilities q three q seven the
dfa is going to have the sub a state
with the subset q3 q7 and it's going to
for every possible subset here there's
going to be a different state of m prime
so n prime is going to be bigger
um
okay so
quickly the construction of m the states
of m prime now um q prime
are going to be the power set
the set of subsets of states
uh from the original machine m
um
and uh
the
uh now we have to look at how the
transition function of the dfa when you
make the primed machines are the dfas as
a dfa machine so these are the prime the
the deterministic component so
delta prime
um when it when it has a subset
that
you know
something like this
um has a has one of its states which
corresponds to a subset of states of m
and it reads an input symbol you just
have to do the updating the way you
would naturally do you're going to look
at every state in r
look at where that can go under a so
there's a bunch of sets there and look
at all the possible
states that could be in one of those
subsets and that's the set of states
that you you could be in that's going to
be the new set of states and that's
going to be the new state of m prime
okay so it's going to be the subset
corresponding to
all of the states that could be in
uh when you apply the transition
function of the non-deterministic
machine um to one of the states in that
in the subset of states that the not a
terminus machine could be in
okay
it's a little bit of a mouthful you know
you you could
i suggest you look at this if you didn't
quite get it after the fact
good to understand
the starting state for the nfa
for the dfa i'm sorry is going to be
which subset now we're going to start
off with it's going to be the subset
corresponding to just the start state
of um
uh of
of m
um
and the accepting states are going to be
uh of the deterministic machine are
going to be all of the subsets that have
at least one accepting state from the
nfa
so i hope you got that because i'm going
to be another little check in here um
which is i'm going to ask you how big is
m prime how many states does n prime
have uh i told you what those states are
so just go think about that um
so check in two if m has n states how
many states does m prime have by this
construction
okay so let's launch the next poll
um
okay
five seconds and i think we're almost
done here
good
all right share results
i know if sharing results is a good
thing i'm not trying to make you if you
didn't get the right answer um because
most of the people did get the right
answer we didn't get the right answer
trying to make you feel bad but i do
think you should it's a little bit of
suggestion you know that you you need to
review some basic concepts so the basic
concept here is if you have a collection
you have a set of states how many
subsets
are there and the number of subsets is
going to be exponential
so if you have a collection of n
elements the number of subsets of those
n elements is 2 to the n
um that's the fact we're using here and
that's why
m prime has two to the n states if m had
n states
um and that's you know you should make
sure you understand why that is
all right
so um with that um
as requested we're gonna have a little
break
um
and that break is going to last us
exactly
five minutes
so we'll we will return in five minutes
i'm going to be prompt so i give you a
little timer here so please
um
uh
i'm gonna
begin it write it right right when this
is over
okay
almost almost ready
i hope you're all refreshed
and ready for the second half
so now now that we have non-determinism
we're going to use uh that as a tool to
prove the uh closure properties that we
were aiming for for um starting from
last lecture
okay um
so remember
we
let's look at closure under a union now
we already did that
but i'm going to do it again
but this time using non-determinism and
you'll see how powerful
non-determinate non-determinism
now determinism is because it's going to
allow us to do it kind of
almost
with no effort
we'll start off the way we did before
i'm going to start off with two
dfas
but actually these could be um nfas even
but let's say we started with the two
dfas for the two languages a1 and a2 and
we're going to construct the nfa rec now
we're going to construct an nfa
recognizing the union
um and that's good enough because we
already know that we can convert nfas to
dfas and therefore they do they do
regulate languages too
um
okay
so now here are the two
dfas that do the languages a1 and a2
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
put them together into a bag of states
um which is going to be m
the
nfa
that's going to do the union language so
remember what does what does
m supposed to do m is supposed to accept
its input if either m1 or m2 accept so
how is it going to do that what it's
going to do we're going to add a new
state
to m
which is going to branch under epsilon
transitions and now you can start to see
how useful these epsilon transitions are
going to be for us going to branch under
epsilon transitions to the two original
start states of m1 and m2 and we're done
y
well now
non-deterministically as we get an input
w coming in to m
um m at the very beginning even just
right after it gets going the very first
thing that happens is it's going to
branch to m1 and also branch to m2
non-deterministically as two
possibilities
and then inside m1 and m2 it's going to
actually start reading the input and
each one is going to be now following
along
as it would have originally
uh
the
states corresponding to um reading those
input symbols
um and
m
as a combination of m1 and m2 is going
to have a possibility for e for one
state in m1 and once one stated m2
um
and so m is going to have those combined
into one in
into one
um package and now if either at the end
of the input if either
um of these end up at an accepting state
then m
[Music]
um
is going to accept as a
non-deterministic fighter automaton
because that's how non-determinism works
you accept if either if any one of the
branches ended up accepting which is
just what you need for non-determinate
for union
so we're doing you and we want either
one of these to be accepting and then
the non-determinism just is built
conveniently to allow us to do the union
almost you know
for free
um
so you can again thinking about
non-determinism as terms of parallelism
you could think of it the
non-deterministic machine is running in
parallel m1 and m2 on the input
and if either one of them ends up
accepting m will accept
or you can think about it in terms of
that guessing that i referred to before
which means that
as m is getting when it's just about to
read these the first symbols of its
input it guesses
whether um that's going to be an input
accepted by m1 or an input accepted by
m2 and the magic of non-determinism is
that it always guesses right
so that input happens to be some an
input that's going to be wrecked you're
going to be accepted by m2
m is going to guess that
m2 is the right way to follow and it's
going to go in the m2 direction
um because non-determinism the magic is
you always guess right
wish that was true in real life
uh would make exams a lot easier um
anyway so
now let's see how we can use that to do
closure under concatenation
okay so now um we're gonna actually have
a picture very similar to the one we had
originally but now using non-determinism
we can make it work
so here we have the two machines doing
the two
languages a1 and a2
and we're going to combine them into one
bigger machine m
as shown
remember what m is supposed to do is
accept its input if there's some way of
splitting that input such that the first
half is accepted by the m1 and the
second part is accepted by m2
way we're going to get that effect
is by
um
putting in
a uh
transit empty
empty transitions epsilon transitions
going from the starts for the except
states of m1 to the start state of m2
just as i've shown here in this diagram
so these were the original accepting
states of m1
and now
um they're going to be declassified as
accepting states but they're going to
have new transitions empty transitions
um
attached to them which allow them to
branch to m2 without reading any input
and so intuitively speaking this is
going to do the right thing
because once m1 has accepted
some
part of w
then you can
non-deterministically
branch to
m2
and um
and you're going to be start processing
inside m2
and the the point is as i kind of uh
jumped ahead of myself um is that the
reason why it fixes the problem we had
before
is that the epsilon transitions are
don't machine does not have to take them
it can
stay where it is
as one non-deterministic option or it
can move along the epsilon transition
without reading any input as another
non-deterministic option
so it's using this non-determinism now
to both
stay in m1 to continue reading more of
the input and to jump into m2 to start
processing what might be the second half
or the second part of the input which m2
accepts
and you can think of it in terms of the
guessing is that the machine is guessing
where to make that split
once it found an initial part that's
accepted by m1 it guesses that this is
the right split point and that passes to
m2 but there might be other guesses that
it could make
you know corresponding to other
possibilities
and so
with non-determinism it always guesses
right if there is some way to split the
string into two parts
uh accepted by m1 and m2 the machine
will make that good guess
and
then
m1 will accept the first part and m2
will accept us with the second part and
we'll get m accepting that whole uh
string uh altogether and so that is the
uh solution um to our uh puzzle for how
do we do closure under concatenation
okay i hope that came through because
this is um this is you know we're just
getting going with non-determinism we're
going to be using non-determinism a lot
and you it's going to you're going to
need to get very comfortable with it
okay um
now let's do closure under star
um
and closure under star
works uh very similarly
but now we're just gonna have a single
language if a is regular so is a star so
they're not a pair of languages because
a star is a urinary operation
applying to just a single uh
language
so if we have a dfa recognizing a in
order to show that a star is regular we
have to construct a machine that
recognizes a star and a machine we're
going to construct is as before and then
an nfa
okay
so um
here is m
uh the dfa for a
and we're going to build an nfa m prime
that recognizes a star
and let's think now what does it mean to
recognize a star
so when should m you know if i'm going
to give you an input when is it in the
star language what does m prime have to
do
um so m remember what star is star means
you can take as many copies of you lot
as you like of strings in the original
language and that's in the star language
so to determine if something's in the
star language you have to see can i
break it up into pieces which are all in
the original language
um
[Music]
so
uh
um
so you want to see can i take my input
w and cut it up into a bunch of pieces
four in this case um where each of those
pieces are members of a they're members
of the original language so that's what
that's what m prime's job is
it's getting it has its input and wants
to know can i cut that input up into
pieces each of which are accepted by the
original machine
m
that's what m prime does
and if you think about it you know um
a little bit
really what's happening is that as soon
as
m
so you know m prime is going to be
simulating m that's why i like to think
about this as having m inside so you
know you're going to if you were going
to be doing this yourself you're going
to take w you're going to run it for a
while you'll see oh m is accepted
now i have to start m over again
to see if it accepts
uh on the next segment
so every time m accepts you're going to
restart m to see if it accepts another
segment and so you by doing that you're
going to be cutting w up into different
segments which are each of which is
accepted by m
of course
it's never totally clear
whether you should
and for any given segment you should cut
it there or you should wait a little
longer and find another play a later
place to cut but that's exactly the same
problem that we had before with
concatenation
and
we saw that using non-determinism and
we're going to solve it again using
non-determinism
so the way we're going to get that
effect of starting the machine over
again once once it's accepted is by
adding in
epsilon transitions that go from the
start states back to the
from the accept state back to the start
state
so now every time
m has accepted it has an option not not
a requirement but it has an option it
can either stay continuing to process
or it can restart
making a cut at that point and
trying to
see if there's a yet a different a
second another segment of the input
that's going to be ex that it's going to
accept
and this is basically the whole thing
with one little
um
problem
that we need to deal with
and that is
we need to make sure
um that m prime
accepts the empty string because
remember the x empty string is always a
member of the
starred language
and as it's as it's
written right now
we're going to be requiring there to be
at least one copy
of one at least one segment we're not
taking into account the possibility of
no segments which is the empty string
and the way we're going to get that
is well i mean
one thing
one way to get to it
so you know we're missing the empty
string right now so how do we fix it
basically you know we're just going to
take the construction we have
get uh you know on on the screen and
we're going to uh
adjust it to to add in the empty string
because it's possibly missing
one way to do that
which is tempting but
wrong
is to
make the start state of m an accepting
state for m prime
so we could have and we could have made
this an uh an accepting state too
and now m prime is also going to accept
the empty string that's the good news
the problem is that
the start state might be playing some
other role
in m besides just being the start there
might be times when m comes back to the
start state
you know later on
and if we make the start state the
accept and accept state it's going to
suddenly start accepting a bunch of
other things too which might not be
intended
so it's a bad idea to make the start
state and accept state
instead we'll take the simples uh
solution alternative of adding a new
start state
which will never be returned to under
any circumstances and make that a new
start and accept state as well so here
we'll have to make this additional
modification
so as i'm saying this is what we need to
do and we will do that
is by adding a new start state which is
also an accept state to make sure it
accepts the empty string
and then that also can branch
um to start off m
as before
um if the string that's input is not the
empty string and so then m you know we m
prime is actually going to have to do
some work to see if it can be cut up as
it was going as it was doing before
um so
that's
the proof of closure under star i'm not
going to do it anything beyond what i've
just described these proofs by picture
are convincing enough i hope um
and if not you know you should they are
explained in somewhat more detail
somewhat more formally in the textbook
but uh for the lecture this is where i'm
going to stop with these these two
arguments
um and so now uh oh yeah one uh quick
check in on this
so if m has n states
how many states does m prime have by
this construction
um so let's do
really these are
i'm not intending these to be very hard
more just to keep you awake
uh
so
how many
states does
m prime have
okay
maybe a little too easy even for a
check-in
yeah everybody's getting this one um
because all you did was we added one new
state um so the answer is as you have um
i think should pretty much everybody is
uh observing that it's just the um
it's number b um so i'm gonna end the
polling
i'm gonna share the results
and everybody got that one and so let's
continue on
um
and uh
so um
the very last thing we're going to do
today and show you how to convert
regular expressions
to nfas
thereby showing that every language that
you can describe with a regular
expression is a regular language
on tuesday we'll show how to do the
conversion in the other direction and
show thereby showing that these two
um
methods of describing languages are
equivalent to one another so here is our
theorem if r is or is a regular
expression and a is the language is
instead of strings that like that
regular expression describes then a is
regular
okay
um
so um we're going to show how to convert
[Music]
the the strategy is to convert r to an
equivalent nfam
and
so we have to think about remember these
regular expressions uh that we
introduced last time these are these
expressions that look like um you know a
b union b star something like that
um so built up out of the regular
operations from um
from the from the primitive regular
expressions that don't have any
operations that we're calling atomic
so if r is an atomic regular expression
it just looks like
either just a single symbol or an empty
string symbol or a
an empty language symbol
[Music]
or
r can be
a composite regular expression um
whoops
we're having a little
yeah so
so we have two possibilities here um r
is either atomic or composite
and so let's look at what the equivalent
expression is um in each case
so if r is just the single letter
regular expression that's a totally
legitimate regular expression just a
regular expression
one
so that just describes the language of
the string one
so we have to make a an nfa
which accepts which recognizes just that
language accepts only the string one
so it's a very simple nfa
it just starts uh in the start state and
on that single symbol it branches to an
accept state and there were no other
transitions allowed so if you get
anything else coming in besides that one
that that string which is just that one
symbol
the nfa is going to reject it
like if it goes if it's too long if if
you know if it gets a a coming in well
there's nowhere to go on from this um
accepting state on an a so the machine
is just going to die
it has to be in an accept state at the
end of the input
um how about you know why don't you
think for yourself for a minute how do
we make an nfa which
uh accepts only the empty string and no
other strings
you can do that with just one state with
an nfa
just this one here
um the machine is going to start off in
the start state which is also
immediately an accept state so it
accepts the empty string
but if anything else comes in there's
nowhere to go when the machine does
so this machine accepts just the empty
string or its language is the language
with one element the empty string
how about the empty language
well here's a here's an nfa which
has no accepting state so it can't be
accepting anything
now if we have a composite regular
expression
we're already finished because we showed
how to build up
we showed constructions which uh give us
closure under union
uh concatenation and star and those
constructions are going to enable us to
build up
uh the
nfas
that do
the language of these more complex
regular expressions built up out of the
anaphase that do the individual parts
so if we already have anaphase that do
r1 and r2
then
the closure under union construction
gives us an nfa that does
r1 union r2
as a language
so i'm going to do
i hope that's clear but i'm going to do
an example which will help hopefully
illustrate it and it's going to show you
you know basically what i'm giving you
is an automatic procedure for converting
a regular expression into an equivalent
nfa
so let's just see if
that that procedure in opera in action
which is really just following this
recipe that i described for you so here
is a regular expression a union a b
star
so this is a regular expression
it's some language whatever it is i
don't care
but i want to make an nfa which
recognizes that same language
and the way i'm going to do that is
first build nfa for the
[Music]
components um
the sub-expressions of this regular
expression
and then combine them using our closure
constructions
to be
um
to be anaphase for larger and larger
sub-expressions until i get the n of a
that's the equivalent of the entire
expression so let's just see how that
goes so the the very most primitive
parts the the the smallest
sub-expressions here are just the
expressions for a and for b
so here's the one for a just
just for a
so this is the nfa which um
recognizes the language which is just
the one string a
here's the nfa for the just whose
language is just the one string b
um
and now
i want an nfa which is
which accepts only the string a b
now of course you could just do that by
hand
um yourself it's simple enough but what
i'm arguing is that you we can do this
automatically
using the closure construction for
concatenation because really there's an
there's a hidden concatenate
concatenation symbol this is the the you
know a concatenate b
so now for a b
i'm going to take
um the the thing from a
and the part from b
so these these two things that i had
from before
and use the concatenation construction
to combine them
you see that so now i have automatically
a an nfa which does the language whose
string is just a b
th just the a b string
and
it's not the simplest nfa you can make a
simpler one but the virtue of this one
is that i got it automatically
just by following the closure
construction so now i'm going to do a
more complex one just the inside here a
union a b
um
so the way i'm going to build that is
from the two parts the a part and the a
b part
you know the a part and the a b part
so here is the a part
here's the a b part a b part i've
already got those from before it's
really kind of a proof by induction here
but you know i think it's simple enough
we don't have to use that language um
so we have
um
you know the a part the a b part and now
we are going to apply the
uh
the
closure under union construction to
combine those into one machine and
remember how that worked
we add a new symbol here which branches
under empty string to the previous
uh
i'm adding a new start state which
branches to the original start states
under empty empty transition and now
this is a an nfa for this language a
union a b
and lastly now we're one step away from
getting uh the star of this
and how we're going to do that
we're going to take this thing here and
apply the construction for the star
closure
and that's going to be an nfa which does
a union a b star which is what we wanted
in the first place
so
first we're going to
bring that one down because we've
already built that one and now remember
how we built um the
uh closure under star
we made this the accepting states return
back to the um the start state and we
added a new start state to make sure we
got the empty string in there
that transitioned to the original star
state under epsilon
okay so that's all
um i wanted to say for today's lecture
let's do a quick review
um
we
very important concept non-determinism
and and non-deterministic finite
automata we proved their equivalent in
power
uh
showed the class of regular languages
closed under concatenation and star we
showed how to do conversion of regular
expressions to nfas
so um i think that is it for
today's lecture and um
thank you all for being here
let me i'll try to answer a few of these
why does concatenation have order well
because it's an ordered construction
um
is there a simple way to prove closure
under concatenation without using
non-determinism no
um
why are the empty strings at the accept
state can't they be at any state
doesn't star make copies of any part of
the input no it's only you have to
you have to think about what's going on
having you you don't want to you have to
branch back to the beginning only on an
accept because that means you found a
piece that's in the original language um
is there an automaton that can add some
some or subtract
memory automata
well
depends on what you mean by all that but
um
certainly there are more powerful
machines that we're going to study than
find out automata um so
um
but yes there is um and even finite
automata can add and subtract if you
present the input in the right way i re
refer you to the first problem on the
homework um
so i think i'm gonna
uh check out then um
take care everybody bye
you